[Music]
70 million what's good go home
name review it's time for YouTube's
favorite show everybody meme review
that's right welcome um Who am I the
meme ster
recently I was looking through my
daughter's phone and I found many
pictures of a cartoon skeleton with one
glowing blue eye and wearing the hoodie
when I asked my daughter why she had
such a demonic images on her phone she
told me there was nothing wrong with it
because it was from a video game how do
I help my daughter not be attracted to
such a demonic thing meme review
everybody
the first meme let's get jump into it
what meme am I gonna have to kill today
Kowalski analysis that's right it's time
boy it's time to die you dumb meme am I
the only one that doesn't get this mean
i'ma do am I just supposed to pretend
that I think this is funny cuz it's not
I guess I it's damn time this meme dies
I feel like this is one of those memes
where half of the people posted is like
yeah I get the joke who else you just
had the Kowalski analysis afterwards and
then it's funny allow calendar to access
your calendar Kowalski analysis
okay fine fine when you install adblock
but then all the hot singles in your
area disappear Kowalski analysis I mean
to be fair that makes no sense
when you with your girl and she said she
needs to take a wee-wee but you remember
that P is stored in the balls
Kowalski it's always good to combine a
diamine with a already dead mean that's
how you know they this mean was over
before it even began
everyone knows P is stored in the brain
just like men's [ __ ] woman in sumo
wrestler suit assaulted her
ex-girlfriend in gay pub and she waved
that man dressed as a Snickers bar ha
weird flex but okay
well being gay isn't necessarily an
indication of femininity gay sex is the
manliest kind of sex because there are
no women involved in it Kowalski you
goddamn right how about that can we have
a meme like that you goddamn right about
that son this meme is from the future
you don't get to reference yet holy heck
er
time-travel is real guys this was a year
ago I still don't get it
Kowalski anal yeah 18 year olds the
world 14 year old Kowalski a no I mean
analysis wait is she 14 okay but like if
you didn't know she was 14 but like how
are you supposed to know guys how the
Frick am I supposed to know it's a 14
year old and cannot doubt which I would
just kick out of the window is 18th this
is why Japanese isn't fair I'm a college
student what does this mean what does
this mean see no wonder this is one of
those memes that just you just put
anything I'm tired of it
it's gonna be my pleasure to review this
onii-chan I'm legal I'm 20 oh this meme
gets it three okay I don't want to see
it ever in my life again I Spit on it
head tuck spit on it twice that's how
you know it's cursed forever be gone
next me looks like it's time for special
news report with poppy Harlow good
evening
I'm poppy Harlow and you're watching a
special new segment of pew news special
it would appear that none other than the
March Super Mario from Super Mario 64
and other various Nintendo titles have
in fact died reports said Mario was
texting and driving at the time of the
incident
Mamma Mia I shouldn't have texted while
driving was his last dying words oh my
god Mario in text and drive I am shaking
crying right now our thoughts go out to
his family his friends and loved ones
special
nice I have something very serious to
tell you something that I have never
told anyone on my 8 years career of
YouTube a revolt is a secret around
t-series and here it goes bra bra bra oh
my god have you guys heard this meme
this meme is crazy
honestly the bra meme is so is so good I
don't know if you guys seen this like
vine thing but like they they have these
things right bra bra oh not now son
daddy not now son dad not now son son
bra this mean get the pen everybody it's
a free content it's a freaking thing the
bra meme it's gonna just it's the meme
of the year it's a meme of the year meme
of the everybody and the Grammy goes to
a bra sound effect to browse sound
effect - I'm crying I'm shaking and
crying right now
follow your dreams than anything can
become true next me never say the n-word
and take it from an amateur take it from
a light-hearted student I'm gonna say
the n-word
mrs. Obama I've done it I've stopped
racism thank you skip it now I am free
to roam this earth not if I have
anything to say about it and I do I'm
gonna say the n-word I'm doing you a
favor here
if you're ever in this situation just
say bruh just say bruh I'm gonna say the
n-word
this meme get said important status next
I mean this is said this is it this is a
very listen I'm just a news reporter you
can't put me I'm just reporting the news
memes okay I'm not another one making
them so you can't blame it on me if
they're bad
alright kind of think of an analogy of
how I feel about this me like when an
ugly girl gets a crush on you it's like
I don't want that but it's also like
well it's the only female who's ever
given me attention you know what I mean
that's how I feel about this mean weird
flex but okay I kill them all not just a
man but their women and children too
weird flex but okay now everyone has
taken it upon themselves on the Internet
to literally type really anything it's
gone too far
I'm sick of it I married my best
friend's dead and now I'm her stepmom
weird flex this reminds me that my very
first email was flexed 89 don't you dare
say it don't you chills myself god it's
okay I mean no odd flicks but okay what
I spent on gummies you'll probably spend
on gas so bad so bad weird flexed but
okay huh who would've thought that would
have happened someone took the literal
context of a meme never done her that
deceived by that before Guinness world
record books are just long list of odd
flexes and the woke level of them mean
my wife I'm leaving and taking kids with
me we had flex but okay it's not a weird
flex but and it's not okay am I the
first one to say this it's not okay stop
flexing and stop okay I'm sick of it
seeing other people living happy
successful and fulfilling lives
weird flex but okay this is not a weird
flex but okay shut the hell up learn how
to mean like a real meme stir and stop
it you're not funny
you're pathetic kids are literally
posting everything anything at any time
I tweet these days
weird flex Budokan
- shut the hell up red flicks motoki
literally and while we're talking about
his image okay someone pointed out that
I walk like a virgin wish I don't okay
I walk like an absolute chat you look at
this and we're gonna go through the
whole thing all right back slouched
maybe a little bit okay all right fine
hair seemed to overreact to win do you
see that pristine hair this haircut
doesn't move for anything all right
so one one head crane forward well
obviously because I'm whatever just shut
the hell up
I'm not a virgin this stupid me get zero
okay stop weird flexing everyone stop if
I say a single goddamn comment talking
about.we pre-committed key all right
I'll kill you that's right this is a
threat what are you gonna do shut this
video down for online harassment like I
care
I got YouTube's number of dial I'll call
them up right now hey Susie meme review
everybody YouTube's favorite show
do we have time for bonus me calling
psych do we have time for bonus mean
[Music]